So now let's look at the performance of MOVZ
and MOVN type of if conversion. In the previous quiz
we have already seen that branch code like this
can be if converted into code like this. Let's suppose
that this branch here is perfectly predicted, so all
we have to worry about is this one. And let's
say that this branch is 80% accurately predicted. And let's
say there is a 40 instruction penalty on missed predictions.
In that case, we have, here, this costs us four instructions.
This costs us three instructions on this path, or two instructions on this
path, let's say it's a very difficult to predict branch. So it's
not biased, in which case we have 2.5 instructions
all the time, plus 20% of the time, we have a 40
instruction panel. This gives us on average 10.5 instructions worth of work
on this, versus four here, so obviously, that if converted code is more optimal.